I would say that the most important value of
this recent publication of
theropods, a very special lineage of
dinosaur animals and which
also includes modern groups of birds, is
that no information was known from such
high latitudes in South America.
This is the factual finding of
southernmost theropods in South America and
with the exception of Antarctica the
southernmost in the world
the last one
the discovery mainly consisted of
finding in rescuing
fossil dental elements not true begins
fossils of teeth in
the valley of China and these pieces
had a characteristic a
singularity  that allowed us to
interpret them and refer to the
megaraptor dinosaurs megaraptor dinosaurs
are large carnivorous carnivores
that inhabited Gondwana mainly
in South America where we have the largest
number of records and belong to a
rather special club of
enigmatic dinosaurs because we still do not know for
sure  what are your afi  taxonomic units,
studies are showing a
tremendous collection of this
southern region of South America with New Zealand
and Australia and therefore theropods
come to complete part of that
information, they also give us a
much more up-to-date vision
regarding ecology